Speaker 1: So yesterday on the world famous
and award winning bonus show producer Pat and
I talked about the reality that British Prime
Minister Liz Truss is days may be numbered,
even though it had only been like six weeks
since she came to power. And indeed we woke
up this morning in the United States to the
news that British Prime Minister Liz Truss
has resigned after only 43 days in office.
Truss as a member of the Conservative Party,
also known as the Tory Party. And you started
to get the sense that maybe this wasn't going
to be particularly long lived when the idea of
cutting taxes on the rich was first presented
at a particularly inopportune time, given what
was going on in the British economy, and then
very quickly abandoned, it already sort of wasn't
looking particularly good. And then now indeed a
CNBC reporting UK Prime Minister Liz Truss resigns
after failed budget and market turmoil. That's
putting it lightly, writing that on September
23rd Truss is Finance Minister. A minister Kwasi
Kwarteng announced a so-called mini budget which
began a turbulent period for UK bond markets,
which balked at the debt funded tax cuts he put
forward. Most of the policies were reversed three
weeks later by the second Finance Minister, Jeremy
Hunt. That's already a bad start. And indeed,
now the resignation comes amid financial market
turmoil and a revolt within the Conservative
Party, as is often the case in politics, defiant
until the very end just a day earlier. Check out
this video. Listen to this audio. Defiant saying
I am not a quitter. And of course, we know what
happened just hours later. This is yesterday.
Speaker 2: Mr. Speaker,
I am a fighter and not a quitter.
Unidentified:
I have acted in the national interest to make
sure that we have economic stability. Order!
Speaker 3: Order! I'm going to hear the
Prime Minister. I suggest the old members
need to hear the answer. Prime Minister.
Speaker 2: Mr. Speaker. I am a fighter.
We have delivered on the energy price
guarantee. We have delivered on the
energy price guarantee. We've delivered
on national insurance. We are going to
deliver to stop the militant trade unions. This.
Railways. The honorable gentleman has no idea.
Speaker 1: And of course, ultimately what she
delivered was a resignation announcement this
morning very early US time, morning time in
the UK. Let's take a look at that. How quickly
political fates can, of course, reverse.
Speaker 2: Given the situation? Yes, I.
Speaker 1: Can a much a much more
sober sounding Liz Truss this morning.
Speaker 2: Not deliver the mandate on which I
was elected correct by the Conservative Party.
I have therefore spoken to His Majesty the King,
to notify him that I am resigning as leader of the
Conservative Party. While this morning I met the
chairman of the 1922 committee, Sir Graham Brady,
we've agreed that there will be a leadership
election to be completed within the next week.
This will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and national security.
Speaker 1: A bit late for that, actually.
Speaker 2: I will remain as prime minister
until a successor has been chosen. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Yes, a very, very clear and definitive
resignation there. This makes Liz Truss the
shortest prime, shortest lived prime minister
in the history of the UK. The previous shortest
died rather than quit. So this is really quite
significant. Liz Truss 43 days and prior to Liz
Truss, the shortest lived prime minister was
George Canning, whose term lasted 119 days.
You have to go back to the period April 12,
1827 to his death on August eight, 1827. Now,
one perspective on all of this is that this is
really less about Liz Truss and Boris Johnson
than it is about the disconnect between the
Conservative Party and the majority. Of the
people in the United Kingdom. And the idea is
that trust was essentially a scapegoat. And so
you could kind of take it step by step. Well,
the Tory Party has been the Tory Party for a
long time. Of course, tax cuts for the rich,
it's like Republicans in that sense, no matter
what you see, no matter what nail or screw or
tile or piece of flooring you see, you're
only tool is a hammer. So you figure, well,
I'll take the hammer too, whatever it is, even if
it doesn't make sense to start hammering a tile.
And the Boris Johnson resignation was more about
his particular bad acts than it was about policy.
But then sort of seeing the writing on the wall
and that this is really not the time economically
for someone with this policy, the idea is, well,
it was clear that whoever replaced Boris Johnson,
Liz Truss or whoever else. Mr.. IN Right. It was
going to be if the policies were those of the Tory
Party, it was going to be a sort of sacrificial
lamb, it was going to be a scapegoat, whatever,
to go up there and say, Yeah, we're still going
to do the tax cuts. Obviously we're not. That
gets abandoned, they suffer and then they move on.
And now whoever is next, again, this is the idea.
Whoever is next now won't suggest the tax cuts for
the rich, which would be particularly ill timed
right now and maybe we'll be able to have a longer
tenure. The other idea is that all of this, this
is just going to be a loop until eventually the
Conservative Party is removed from power and that
it's just a matter of time and it's just a number
of scapegoats or sacrificial lambs between now
and then. I don't know. But an extraordinary bit
of global news there. 43 days as prime minister.
Imagine if we had this sort of process in the
United States, that would really be something.